good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric Gershon over the epochs
and ages our planet has spawned a
fantastic diversity of life today we
talk about some of the remarkable
species that have come and gone or
morphed into something that lives among
us now our guest and guide is
paleontologist Derek Briggs director of
Yale's Peabody Museum of Natural History
and a leading figure in one of the most
celebrated projects in modern
paleontology the analysis of British
Columbia's burgess shale as always we'll
take some of your questions please
submit them via Twitter - at Yale or by
email to social media at yale.edu Derek
Briggs thanks for being with us a
pleasure let's start with the word
paleontology for me and I suspect for a
lot of people the first thing that
springs into your mind when you hear
that is dinosaurs paleontology concerns
itself with a lot more than dinosaurs
what was it that first interested you in
paleontology and how have your interests
evolved so to speak well paleontology is
certainly about a lot more than
dinosaurs although of course dinosaurs
are our best friend because they they
get the public interested in
paleontology and in in many respects
they they introduce the public to
science in many cases I was raised in
Ireland which doesn't have any dinosaurs
so in some sense I was the least likely
paleontologist because our home was on
the Leicester granite which is not going
to be a very good source of fossils I
went to Trinity College Dublin and it
was essentially about the people that
taught me there the geologists were some
of the most interesting and I got very
excited about the discipline and when I
graduated I decided I would like to do
graduate work somewhere else
and I was fortunate enough to be offered
this project in Cambridge which as you
said involved the Burgess Shale with
with Harry Whittington who was my my
graduate student adviser so that's in
essence how I really got into to
paleontology was at Cambridge as a
graduate student I want to follow up
with you about the Irish soil what is it
about the landmass and I
that doesn't lend it to the preservation
of it doesn't have rocks the right age
to preserve dinosaurs so the Mesozoic
the the rocks of the appropriate age are
fairly few and far between and those
that are there are essentially marine as
opposed to terrestrial so Ireland
doesn't have much of dinosaurs that one
can celebrate let's talk about the
Burgess Shale if you would give us a
quick overview of why this location in
Canada is so legendary in in the field
and what the work that you and your
colleagues and others have done there
how its helped change the way that we
understand the history of life I mean
the most important thing about the
Burgess Shale in a sense is its age it's
a Cambrian deposit so it's about five
hundred and ten million years old and
it's it's a little while after the
beginnings of what we call the Cambrian
explosion and the Cambrian explosion is
that event which gave rise to all the
major groups that are around today I
mean everything from you know slugs and
snails to ourselves to vertebrates so
it's a critical interval in in the
evolution of life on Earth today the
Burgess Shale is particularly special
however because in contrast to most
localities it yields far more than just
the normal shells so it it preserves
evidence of the soft tissues as well as
the hard parts and given that the
internal organs of the internal organs
that the soft tissues that would
normally decay away and given that most
of life is in effect soft bodied I mean
about 60 percent of creatures are are
essentially soft bodied and therefore
rot away without these kinds of
extraordinary preservations we wouldn't
have evidence of many of the life-forms
that appeared at that time and this
locality had been discovered back in the
early part of the 20th century by a man
called Charles Walcott who was at the
Smithsonian
so major collections are at the
Smithsonian
my advisor at Cambridge Harry
Whittington was recruited while he was
still at Harvard to start a project by
the Geological Survey of Canada because
the Canadian science community I think
realized that most of the material was
in the United States and it was time
that it was revisited and re studied and
they invited him to to run that show so
to speak and he decamped to Cambridge
because he was actually a brace shortly
after the start of the project and then
recruited myself and Simon Conway Morris
as graduate students and that's how we
how we got involved and the collection
of fossils there's both numerous diverse
and if I'm not mistaken well preserved
yes a so much new well preserved and the
exciting thing about it is that it's
still being worked in the sense that
there are many other localities in the
general area in British Columbia in Yoho
National Park and indeed outside the
park now that have been discovered since
that preserve a range of these
extraordinary animals in a spectacular
way so the Royal Ontario Museum has been
particularly involved a man called John
Bernard Curran is the curator there now
and they're continuing to collect and
we'll be back there this summer not of
the original wolcott quarry but at other
localities in the vicinity where
extraordinary fossils are still coming
out give us a sense if you would
contrast some of the extraordinarily
well-preserved fossils at Burgess with
what you might call a typical fossil
well if we take a trilobite which will
be known to some of the people watching
in the sense that these are a very
popular group of fossils that look what
is there a modern they look a bit like
pill bog pill bugs or isopods I mean
they have a series of segments and a
head and tail and they were very common
during the Paleozoic and equally so in
the Cambrian those things have a hard
mineralized dorsal skeleton and that's
routinely preserved but if you take the
Burgess examples not only is the the
outer skeleton preserved but also the
limbs and the gut
and the internal or crisis of the
internal organs so you get the complete
animal and equally you get animals that
normally don't get preserved at all that
simply wouldn't be present I mean things
like equivalent to jellyfish or soft
bodied mollusks or whatever and what
about your work and and that of
paleontologist involves my new
examinations of the anatomies of all
kinds of creatures what are some of the
the sort of big picture lessons that
that you and your colleagues derived
from the Burgess in particular about
about about life itself and well I think
I mean several things obviously most
important perhaps is that the explosion
is just that everything appears in
relatively short order over a period of
millions of years and and all the major
groups that we see today have early
representatives back in the Cambrian but
the explosion was such that you get a
lot of rather odd-looking animals which
are early offshoots of the modern groups
and those include some very bizarre
kinds of organisms an animal called opa
binya is one of my favorites and this is
a thing with five eyes on the head and a
long proboscis with a kind of claw like
structure at the end which we think it
used to probe the sediment to pull out
you know lunch in the form of worms or
whatever there's a group of giant
predators called anomaly carrots that
got up to maybe six feet long which had
a pair of claw-like appendages at the
front which they used to you know sweep
up prey so there are animals there that
that we wouldn't recognize as familiar
today but when you study them in detail
it's quite clear that their descendants
cannot they descended so much is this
the same lineages continue today even
though they were sort of early
unsuccessful offshoots of that now these
are all marine animals is that discuss
they're all marine yes is that a
coincidence or what is it about I don't
know the evolution of the Earth's say
that in geology that has yielded this
incredibly rich deposit of marine
animals well life on land took a while
to get going and you didn't really start
until significantly later so the kinds
of organisms that might have been on
land at that stage would have been near
shore maybe algae or slimes or that kind
of thing so nothing that's particularly
interesting so the origins of the
terrestrial groups also in some cases
appear in the Cambrian but they don't
actually get out onto land until much
later on so life in the Cambrian was
essentially marine so that's where the
fossil record is at that time let me ask
you about mass extinction as I
understand it there have been several
maybe five or so major mass extinctions
some of which wiped out the vast
majority of all things plant an animal
that were alive on the earth at the time
obviously bad for those individuals and
bad for the species good for
paleontologists that is have have mass
extinctions been an especially good
source of material not really I mean
mass extinctions are events in the
evolution of life which is you say
involve wiping out large parts of the
biosphere that doesn't necessarily mean
that the potential for getting
fossilized increases and indeed one of
the real challenges of studying mass
extinctions has been looking at the
details of the record and tying them
down to a particular age or date because
you need complete sequences of fossils
to show where that event occurred so
there's no correlation between the
number of fossils that survived and the
mass extinctions themselves I mean that
the Late Cretaceous one that that
removed the rest of the dinosaurs if you
like it about 65 million years ago was
largely down to a major impact of a
bolide from outer space that kind of
event doesn't necessarily mean that you
get more things fossilized at precisely
that point in time but it does mean that
large parts of life at that time were
were wiped out both on land and in the
oceans so how do paleontologists think
about
extinction and is it is it is it is it a
concept that you have to wrestle with
very much yes I mean it's it's routine
and inevitable in the sense that by and
large organisms only last for a certain
length of time and then disappear or
give rise to other forms of life mass
extinctions are those events where
there's significantly higher level of
removal if you like normally due to some
kind of event or some combination of
circumstances so we think of mass
extinctions as exceeding the normal
threshold of background extinction and
clearly people now talk about the sixth
mass extinction which will be in a sense
down to us as as humans and the kind of
environmental impact we have and that's
about what's disappearing and and in
particular the rate at which it is
disappearing and what kind of effect
that's likely to have I guess you know
you could take one of two views about
extinction and mass extinctions one is
that at least the past ones one is that
it could be kind of a downer because it
seems safe to assume that we'll go
extinct at some point too but taking a
bigger less parochial view it's it's
heartening that life has rebounded every
time yes no rights life is certainly
rebounded but it rebounds on an
extraordinarily long time scale rather
to the one that you and I are familiar
with so on a human time scale you know
we can't think of recovery in that sense
it takes millions of years and has done
is there is there a reliable estimate
for the number of species that have ever
lived
no we don't really know even how many
species around the world today I mean
that's one of the major challenges for
biologists now to document what is
actually on the planet before it gets
extinguished so estimates of the number
of species that have ever lived are
based on extrapolations from what we
know of the fossil record and what we
know of the diversity in certain parts
of the globe today but there are no
precise numbers that are reliable let me
ask you about a species I believe it's a
new species that was has been in the
news in the last
few days I guess scientists in Argentina
have discovered a new dinosaur that
they've called the titanosaur
and I guess it's the the the latest
biggest dinosaur known to man big
dinosaurs big things they're appealing
to everyone for their their novelty put
us in the mind of a paleontologist
though what are the other kinds of
questions the the a serious academic
paleontologist going to be trying to
he's going to ask himself and/or herself
and try to learn about life with this
broadly with this kind of discovery I
mean I mean this thing is I've seen
pictures as obviously you have it's
colossal
there's a wonderful picture on the web
of an Argentinean scientist I suspect or
excavator at least lying next to the
femur of this thing and it considerably
greater than the height of him so I
think this thing was about 20 meters
high and maybe 40 meters long Argentina
seems to be blessed with a number of
these huge dinosaurs as you say these
titanosaurs so what will they be asking
is it new and clearly given its size I
think it's highly likely that it that it
is to what extent can they reconstruct
it completely because skeletons don't
always in fact it's unusual for a
skeleton to remain intact and my
understanding is they have several
individuals so I suspect they'll be able
to piece that together and then what
kind of impact will it have had on the
ecosystem at the time this was a Late
Cretaceous sauropod so it was one of
those massive herbivores and you can
think about here the amount of
vegetation required to keep large
numbers of these things going what if
anything was preying on them what kind
of impact I had is to say on the on the
the general ecosystem of the time but
but these discoveries are very exciting
and of course they keep paleontology on
and on the pages of the news and and or
science and indeed science in general I
mean many of us of course get interested
in science in the first place because
we're excited about dinosaurs
let me take a question for
remember the public who this is a
question about museums
it's about museums and science linking
together you're the director of the Yale
Peabody Museum Kaitlin McQuaid
Facebook's us to ask what are the best
ways that you found to connect museum
visitors in the rest of your community
with the research that your scientists
are doing well ideally you keep your
exhibits changing as far as possible so
that at the Peabody we've always had
this philosophy that we will use Peabody
research or Yale research and
incorporate it as far as possible into
our exhibits so for example we presently
have an exhibit called tiny Titans which
is about baby dinosaurs and they're eggs
that includes some research done by
Peabody curators but it also includes
materials from our own collections that
we put on display to if you like augment
the exhibit so we have spectacular birds
eggs and bird's nests because those are
the closest things to living dinosaurs
so it's about keeping your collections
and your research in the exhibit program
as far as possible and our approach is
to do lots as far as possible of
temporary exhibits that's how we bring
back repeat visitors and also when we
have the resources to renew our
permanent exhibit mm-hmm I'm gonna
follow that with a question from Steve
Bryant who also by Facebook and I'm a
butcher the pronunciation but you'll
correct me he wants to know if there any
plans for the Peabody to acquire
ambergris oh I'm Berkeley we have
ambergris is material produced from
sperm whales we have some indeed I did a
quiz for our members dinner a week or
two ago and I what I do at that quiz is
I put all objects out and give them a
series of possible solutions
ambergris was one of the ones that the
collections people offered me as a
potential but we thought passing it
round at the dinner table and people
handling it might not be exactly ideal
so if he wants to come in and see that
week
certainly do I see so it's it's not on
display oh you know it's not on display
that is true that we certainly have some
of the collections and like like many
great museums am i right that there's a
great deal in the possession of the
Peabody that you're that isn't on
display all the time well yes I mean we
we have about 13 billion objects I like
to say roughly 13 million that I'm still
counting them no we have a we have a
huge collection which ranges through
everything from fossils which we're
talking about this afternoon to
historical scientific instruments and
and everything in between and you might
say why and the answer is very simple I
mean we're essentially a resource for
research scientists not just at Yale or
even in North America but right across
the world we have visitors who come in
and work on our materials and we we
steward those for for future generations
but we also use our collections very
much in undergraduate teaching so we
reckon that we know that more than a
thousand Yale undergraduate a year take
courses that use the Peabody collections
everything from ornithology to egg
theology to various kinds of
paleontology so the collections are
vital not just for display but also for
the research community and for our own
students and of course from time to time
we get query some other kinds of
individual as well and we accommodate
those I mean that's essentially what our
mission is let's talk about horseshoe
crabs for a little bit right um you've
done some work on horseshoe crabs I've
done some work on horseshoe crabs yes
and and I've always think thought of
them as a sort of evolutionary success
story I mean they've been around more or
less continuously for something like 450
million years yeah even a little longer
actually yes so we have undescribed
examples I have a wonderful locality in
in the lower division of about four
hundred and seventy-five million years I
slip into the jargon for about four
hundred and seventy-five million years
old in near zagara in Morocco in a unit
called the Fez errata formation
south of the Atlas Mountains just into
the into the desert and I'm working it
with one of my postdocs peter van roy
who's a from belgium and effectively
discovered this material he's working on
horseshoe crabs from fez owatta which
some of which are very similar to living
ones so yes they go back about 475
million years ago so what's the secret
of their success hard to say I think in
essence they were probably generalists
and they're still generalists so they
were able to cope with changes in their
circumstances because they didn't depend
on any single resource um or probably
very tolerant of of changes in their
environment and their food sources and
and so on so adaptable adaptable so in a
sense that's speculative but there's
obviously good evidence that they've
persisted for this length of time yeah
we have other extraordinary horseshoe
crabs in a younger locality in England
that I'm also working on it's it's in
Herefordshire on the border between
England and Wales there we have them in
concretions they're much much smaller
but they preserve not just the dorsal
morphology but very good information on
the limbs mhm and if you look at a
modern horseshoe crab it has a set of
appendages at the front that it walks on
and also feeds with and then the gills
are back in the rear part of the animal
um in the case of this I learn an
example there are large numbers of
additional branches on the front limbs
and we can figure out how those evolved
into modern horseshoe crabs and indeed
some people have done work on the
genetics of horseshoe crabs and shown
what controls the presence and absence
of limbs during development and we may
be able to relate that kind of genetic
story to how these things evolved based
on our our fossils so yeah there are
some of my favorite animals I have to
say I read a story in The New Yorker not
that long ago about modern horseshoe
crabs and it sounds like they they may
not be faring as well no they're in
trouble I mean there
used for fishing bait and of course they
were used heavily for that mean they
were I think they still are bled for
their the hemocyanin in their blood so I
think it's like many other resources
were tending to overuse them overuse
them you should know that of course
there are no living horseshoe crabs on
the other side of the Atlantic where I
was brought up so for me you know people
say they look like the sort of dinosaurs
of the invertebrate world my first
meeting with them was actually one of my
peers is a graduate student at Harvard
who kept them in tanks in his office and
I came to visit him and it was love at
first sight
everyone love at first sight yeah I mean
they they just fabulous animals
extraordinary animals so tell us you
you've spent a great deal of time I
imagine out in the field as they say
hunting for fossils and presumably
finding them and bringing them back to
your lab and so on and analyzing them um
do you have any favorite personal fossil
discoveries I think I mean to go back to
the Burgess Shale as as a graduate
student I worked on Walcott's
collections in the National Museum of
Natural History in Washington for months
and months and months never because they
weren't opportunities in those days went
to the field and then when the Royal
Ontario Museum started working on this
material exploring there at the park
with the Ojo National Park I joined some
of the early expeditions and was able to
walk on what I would call virgin scree
slope so where the the rocks spall out
of the outcrop on the mountain and
formed those marvelous slopes down the
sides of the the mountain walking on
those where nobody had been and
literally picking up things that I
recognized because I had looked at them
as a guide you stood in the middle I
would you know would have had the
opportunity that lots of very few others
had yeah so it was that kind of it was
just mind-blowing frankly to just pick
these things up on the side of a
mountain
how has house technology changing the
way paleontologists go about their work
I think in in some fundamental ways I
mean in the end paleontology is about
discovering new fossils and
and using your eye and your brain and
your background to figure out what's
going on it's been transformed by
databases and our ability to analyze
huge databases so we can now look at
patterns of change in diversity through
time in ways that used to be done
I mean figuratively at least on the back
of an envelope with a calculator but we
can now put huge amounts of information
into a computer and recognize for
example those mass extinctions in very
clear and detailed ways that technology
has allowed us to peer into fossils cat
scanning and three-dimensional
reconstruction by computers is now a
very powerful and widely used method for
looking at even the tiniest fossils with
the synchrotron or synchrotrons now
around the world and we also have much
better better methods for analyzing the
chemistry of fossils and understanding
how they get preserved and indeed much
more accurate ways using radioactive
elements to work at the age of fossils
so down into levels of precision that
were unthinkable even a few years ago so
yes in many very fundamental ways the
discipline is has changed to what extent
does the work on the soft tissues depend
on technology that's available now that
wasn't fifty years ago well I mean some
of the imaging is is hugely advantageous
so if you can if you can penetrate using
x-rays or cat scans and get at materials
that are far too delicate to prepare
manually or with chemical methods that's
a huge advantage we can analyze the
composition of different structures
within a fossil and sometimes the
chemistry gives us information about
their nature by comparison with with
modern things so though those kinds of
approaches certainly have changed how we
would do this kind of thing we're not
just reliant on microscopes mm-hmm and
drawing ours are new fossils those still
the sort of scenic one-on of
paleontology that is yes because
otherwise your
you're just working with the same data
yeah so my new discoveries are the
be-all and end-all I mean your new
titles or an Argentine case in point the
people are out there looking for fossils
all the time and every time a new one's
found it's like another piece of a
gigantic jigsaw we don't know how big
the jigsaw is but yes I mean new
discoveries are the bread and butter of
what we do
you can't advance the field without them
in really significant ways correct me if
I'm wrong which you've done some work
with others on the color of ancient
animals yeah contra cloth was dinosaurs
in particular or or maybe several
several creatures but how does that work
that is how do you discern color if
there's nothing to see right this this
was work I did with two of my group one
was jakob Venter who was a graduate
student at the time who looked at the
melanin in squid ink of all things and
melanin squidding preserves quite well
in in fossils we also get melanin in in
feathers and fur it gives that dark
color and we get other kinds of colors
structural colors in insects which we've
also looked at so Maria McNamara who
worked with me as a postdoc and I know
you met her she did some extraordinary
work on fossil insect moths and beetles
looking at how the scales and layering
in the cuticle gives rise to structural
colors which are evident than the
fossils when we get we get examples of
what you would call jewel beetles or
scarab beetles in in deposits in various
parts of the world and those colors
survive they're altered but she worked
out methods using the physics to restore
them to their original color but I
suppose the most spectacular thing we
did was constraining the colors on some
of these feathered dinosaurs from China
which was Jakob Venters work so we were
fortunate we got a little animal called
Angie or nurse a very late jurassic form
which is a bit like a I mean a big
fluffy chicken but I say we were able to
constrain the feather color to
black gray white and and the wonderful
thing about this from the point of view
of the the Public Interest was it has a
it has a crest so it has a kind of Punk
appearance and that crest has mallanna's
ohms in it which are spherical and that
tends to be correlated with red or Rufus
or orange colors so we have this this
sort of black white grey general plumage
and there's marvelous red crest at the
top of it so it really captured
everybody's imagination
outstanding you'll equal trade of
fossils also been in the news in the
last year or so particularly with
respect to dinosaurs in Mongolia if I'm
that's right yes to what extent is this
a a serious problem from the point of
view of academic paleontologists but
we're extraordinarily careful I mean if
you run a museum as I do
you're absolutely obliged to figure out
what the provenance of the material you
might want to acquire is and you never
collect without permission and
increasingly nowadays in collaboration
with local collectors but of course
people around the world make a living
collecting and preparing fossils and
sometimes those things are exported
without proper permits
I mean if they turn up at option or in
museums people generally tend to blow
the whistle and as in the case of that
Mongolian dinosaur my recollection is it
was repatriated back to Mongolia if
that's the case yeah so the right thing
in the end happened I mean a spectacular
specimen so aside from the important you
know moral and social questions what
about the material that it does it
seemed to be you know rampant enough
that private collectors who may be just
like the object as art are hoarding
objects that would be of real interest
to science I'm sure there are collectors
out there that have materials that are
of interest to science I have to say
that my experience is that many fossil
collectors of that kind of people who
buy and sell fossils
are usually people who are very excited
about paleontology and therefore
inevitably get into conversations with
paleontologists and many of those people
have been very generous with allowing
access to their material for study and
in in many cases donating it to museums
when their if you like no longer
interested in keeping it as a collection
or bequeathing it so that it we know
that it'll end up in a museum in the end
and that's of course the best possible
scenario where they have resources they
have interest and they accumulate
fabulous material and then it eventually
ends up being properly described and and
in scientific hands the worry of course
is that not always is the provenance
properly documented and that's often
very important in terms of understanding
the context of the fossil specimen let's
end on a philosophical note as it were
right paleontologists like many
geologists like astronomers study
something that offers a very long time a
very long horizon as it were so is when
you when you think in terms of hundreds
of millions of years right and you spend
all this time with these creatures from
from so long ago how does it affect your
view of humans and our species and sort
of mortality I mean you realize that
we're just a blip in the evolution of
life that you know lots of things have
been out there and lived a great deal
longer existed on wait a longer than we
have but because we now are the first
species to in a real way control our
environment we have an enormous
responsibility which I'm not entirely
sure we're always standing up to and and
taking you on board so and you know I
think that's a message we all of us need
to get out of scientists that we are in
a sense making a mess of things and and
we need to make sure that that stops
Derek Briggs thank you so much for
joining us and at Yale
it's been a real pleasure thanks very
much to all of you for watching and I
hope you'll join us again next time
you